you're out there in the dating world I
am NOT you're in the dating world is
this the kind of stuff that do you talk
about this kind of personal stuff when
you're on a date with someone no you
know what what recently that did happen
and I don't know if this has happened to
you ladies somebody ladies someone you
know who I have never been intimate with
and and really had no plans right just
on like a casual day casual and he asked
was I like you know waxed or Brazilian
or something
the ask he asked that seems incredibly
inappropriate it was inappropriate and
honestly he shouldn't have cared if
there was a forest or a jungle I think
[Applause]
used to be the joyful day when they just
were happy down there yeah
they didn't care if it we're like bald
or whatever it was just like oh my god
the promised land we're here it's not
like hey tell me more what kind of
Disneyland is it private how many rides
are out there you know no I get exactly
what you're talking about now I don't
know what you like and I'm certainly not
asking alright but it says the bush it's
making its way back
[Applause]
yeah it's I have read that I've read
that a lot of doctors recommend that as
well they say it's more hygienic they
think it's better it's healthier women
are ready got a really good publicist
yeah yeah yeah publicist for the book
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
so that's why that blows my mind that
people are talking about this on a date
I am a married man I love my wife I'd
rather not be part of this discussion no
I don't care at all I don't like when
people free ads the same thing with
armpits what are you worried about what
do you care now a woman has one thigh
all shaved I want the armpits
[Applause]
you